monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur le gouvernement le 15
janvier dernier vient de donner des
statistiques 2018 de la politique
migratoire
tous les chiffres sans exception sont en
hausse sauf un celui du traitement de
l'immigration irrégulière l'immigration
régulière est à plus de deux cent
cinquante cinq mille personnes pour 2018
la demande d'asile est en augmentation
de 22% 2018 par rapport à 2010 par
rapport à 2017 et le taux de renvoi dans
les pays d'origine des gens en situation
irrégulière est à peu et à ses petits
assez faible moins de 10% en tous les
cas pour cette année 2010 8
le gouvernement nous dit que tout va
bien puisque pour le budget 2010 9 ne
prévoit pas d'augmentation particulière
singulièrement pour le traitement de
l'asile mais également pour le
traitement de l'immigration irrégulière
le président la république vient de dire
qu' il souhaitait mettre dans le débat
l'immigration et singulièrement
reprendre une idée du sénat qui est
celle des quotas annuels que nous
défendons depuis des années dans cet
hémicycle monsieur mise l'intérieur
comment comptez vous aborder cette année
2010 9 qui s'annonce en matière de
politique migratoire bien au delà de
toutes vos espérances qui plaide pour la
stabilité même sans doute pour tout le
contraire merci pour vos réponses
la parole est au secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministère
le monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous m'interrogez sur les
statistiques annuelles en matière
d'immigration publié effectivement
récemment par le ministère de
l'intérieur comme vous l'avez dit en
2018 nous constatons effectivement une
hausse de 21 6% des demandes
enregistrées par l'ofpra et cette hausse
est notamment due aux flux ce qu'on
appelle les flux secondaire je tiens à
souligner pour répondre à votre question
que notre politique d'immigration
d'accueil est juste et réaliste
nous nous donnons les moyens de
l'accueil dans des délais raisonnables
c'est une volonté forte de la loi
adoptée en septembre 2018 mais nous
procédons aussi à des mesures
d'éloignement
comme le prévoit la même loi de
septembre 2018 la loi asile et
immigration
à ce titre les éloignement forcé sont en
hausse significative et se sont
d'ailleurs
c'est la progression en chiffre la plus
haute depuis le début de cette décennie
ces chiffres témoignent de l'efficacité
de notre politique contre l'immigration
irrégulière
ils ne sont pas le fruit du hasard il
résulte bien sûr de la loi que je viens
de rappeler du 10 septembre 2018 mais
aussi de nos dispositifs de contrôle aux
frontières qui ont été significativement
renforcée sur la frontière franco
italienne sur la franz's run frontière
franco espagnole
je me suis rendu moi même le
gouvernement a nommé un coordonnateur en
charge de renforcer ses contrôles qui
sont maintenant tout à fait effectif
quant au budget de l'année 2019
ce budget donne au gouvernement les
moyens de conduire une politique tout à
fait équilibrée que je rappelle de
garantir le droit d'asile mais aussi de
procéder à des mesures d'éloignement et
ce budget asile immigration il est en
augmentation de près de 7% en 2019
il nous faut cependant reconnaître et
écouter l'inquiétude de nos concitoyens
une inquiétude qui s'est manifesté avec
une virulence particulière à propos du
pacte de marrakech
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
le sénateur que le gouvernement a choisi
de que les problématiques pardon de
l'immigration soit abordée dans le grand
débat qui va se tenir dans les semaines
qui viennent
et ces échanges se tiendront notamment
au regard donc de là la thématique sur
le débat démocratique et la citoyenneté
je vous remercie monsieur je fais et
monsieur le ministre je ne partage pas
votre optimisme depuis de nombreuses
années dans cette maison nous défendons
une autre politique migratoire
la première c'est cette d'accueillir -
mais d'accueillir mieux et beaucoup
mieux que ce qui fait jusqu'à maintenant
la seconde c'est effectivement de
traiter l'asile dans de bons délais mais
de traiter surtout les déboutés du droit
d'asile
or aujourd'hui deux événements vont en
faire jour l'augmentation des demandes
d'asile sera réel en 2019 elle sera même
plus importante peut-être que cette
année le traitement l'immigration
irrégulière en réalité vous avez
beaucoup plus d'obligation de quitter le
territoire national qui ont été
prononcées donc le niveau d'exécution
reste faible quoi que vous en disiez et
que pour l'instant nous avons proposé
des solutions nous au sénat je souhaite
que prétend la république hellénique
l'exécutif prenne en compte ces
propositions singulièrement sur la noce
de quotas et de débat nous falloir cours
mais également sur la notion de visa en
contrepartie de laisser passer
consulaire accordés par les pays sources
merci